so you got fans all over the world and
now you got you got this Shady aftermath
behind you words so things are gonna get
crazy for you yes they're already
getting crazy
um once you go like super crazy with the
hip-hop are you gonna do like a death
metal passion project aha yo you you you
read into my mind yeah like just like
hey yo I gotta I gotta get this out
like even if it's just for me you guys
could like it or not but I gotta get
this one out like yeah probably like um
somewhere down the line because I gotta
I got all my homies that not just
because when I was still in the
Philippines I made homies like that's in
here in the states right like collabing
with the metal stuff I haven't even met
them in person because it's life just
life's you know right who your uh top
five bands ever
infinite annihilator
rings of Saturn
Arc spire
dying fetus
aborted there's a band called aborted
what the [__]
gnarly
we're gonna go listen can we let's
listen to someone boarded at our workout
today hey yo you go crazy what
especially if you get like with a good
zob beforehand you get high and listen
to a boarding oh my gosh bro like it'll
separate the instruments the guitars is
here like like it felt like you best
band name ever
it's declared aborted the best band name
ever
um all right so uh obviously realist is
out with Eminem uh you got tons of music
videos tons of Music out
um you're working on new [__] you're
working on new visuals yep
um anything else you got coming you want
to shout out merch and any I mean you
just had a giant box of clothes
delivered and it was Revenge I thought
we were gonna get a sneak peek at the
new easy Mill merch shout out to Revenge
thanks for the cop bro this is that's
definitely right up your your alley that
one yeah this this looks hella black
metal to me for sure yeah that's black
metal right there yeah
shout out to Black Metal Man now I gotta
go listen to it yo noodle was crazy
because we were talking about Norway
right yeah they even make like
commercials like of black metal bands
promoting like soap toothpaste really
yeah
this are these on YouTube wow wow so
they'll be like do us
yeah brush my teeth with this and then
sometimes they do it like so geniusly
like misleading first it's just like the
straight black metal like music video
you see and then at the end it's like
some Old Spice type I mean out there
that's kind of like their boy bands yeah
for real yo Nori's gotta be have you
been in Norway nope you gotta go man I
got I gotta see what's out there you
gotta go out there when you drop your
desk like uh Vikings came from I think
so
makes sense yeah then dudes like even
now if they didn't grow up as Vikings
their ancestors like or Vikings
and they have to let it out which is
mentally okay with those parents like
sharing their kids stories yeah like and
then that leads to like you know your
dead band member on an album cover oh my
God
wait Melissa bad uh super excited for
you congratulations on everything man
thank you
um I can't wait to hear what uh the the
debut album on Shady aftermath sounds
like because that's a big deal yeah get
Richard I try and live up to
so
man there's got to be a movie to it too
I got something planned but you gotta
you're gonna do visuals for the whole
[__] a movie to go along with everything
I like that
you're directing your own uh videos yes
sir that's dope I mean you got your
hands all over the creative place you're
like a [__] Filipino Russ but but I
feel like it's like this new like wave
of artists like yeah us today in like my
generation like I feel like that's the
market now I mean if you're smart and
you're like with YouTube and the way
software's so easy to get for free if
you want to get it cracked
um like you can like really learn all of
it on your own yep or be at least good
enough to do all of it until you get to
a point where you can have someone else
do your [__] you know
yeah it turns it takes a certain type of
like situation I guess so like if you're
like surrounded with so much [__]
yeah and you like have nothing else to
do so you focus yeah learn [__] and you
can learn [__] on your phone YouTube
University man yes
go to YouTube learn everything whatever
you can learn everything on YouTube
including how to um
you know how to knit knit
change the carburetor out
record your vocals see if the capacitor
is still working the capacitor
defibrillator you know what I mean
whatever that means anyway easy email I
appreciate you brother we're gonna do a
freestyle it's gonna be another video
you guys can check out uh go check out
the new record real estate just dropped
with Eminem and there's gonna be much
more coming from this guy yes sir boom